hi there you know I'm supposed to do
these videos regularly little shorts
here on Instagram about language
learning and encourage everyone to learn
languages but I forgot to do it so I'm
doing it now I'm on the golf course
tomorrow I'm golfing with a Korean guy
so this evening I can practice up my
Korean on link and try to get up ahead
of steam so that tomorrow I can actually
have a good conversation kind of like
you heard a Target golf well that's
target language learning I have a Target
I want to be able to speak with
Ben his name is in Korean so I'm gonna
be working at it tonight
call it target language learning to
match my target golf except most the
time when I hit the ball it doesn't go
straight I hope my language learning is
a little more accurate than my target
golf anyway it's a beautiful day here in
North Vancouver
and good luck to all you language
learners
aim at the Target and hopefully hit it
bye for now